I have four large mercury amalgam fillings and a few smaller ones, some scheduled for removal
soon, and I believe the cavities are there are cavities under the fillings.
This is a wise thing to do at my point.
I do feel peace about it, but I want your opinion.
And if I should continue, how do I incorporate the supplements?
So if you're healthy enough to remove your fillings, if you have mercury fillings, I suggest you do it.
But that has to be a call that you have to make is whether you're healthy enough.
If you feel like you've recovered your health and you feel fairly stable, then do it.
Because you will spill a lot of mercury, do it at a, you know, also depends on how deep they are, how bad, how many you have.
You know, how big of a deal it's going to be for the dentist, how much confidence you have in them.
I think it's always best to get your mercury fillings removed, always best.
But if person is really crashing, they're not doing real well or not feeling well, you could be adding insult to injury try to do it.
So you want to make sure that you feel like you're fairly recovered.
The only thing it would change with the supplements is that if your doctor isn't recommending you do so, you've got to make sure that you're taking a binder.
A binder is a supplement that grabs on the things in the gut.
And typically you don't absorb a lot of this of what's in the supplement itself.
It's going to be typically a clay, like a zealike clay or a bentonite clay activated charcoal is a is a binder.
Full of it could go to the gas and our binders.
She like is the binder.
Those are things that you want to be taking if you're getting your mercury removed.
Also, it can be beneficial if you're taking key layers.
So a key later is something that you absorb that grabs on the stuff in your blood and in your tissues.
Because the idea is you're going to go with drill these mercury fillings out.
They're going to gasify you're going to breathe them in no matter if you have your nasal cannulated and all the protection possible.
You're going to absorb some some is going to go into your body by you removing these.
So you want to be grabbing it up to as much as you can.